you love name dropping you love the
celebrities love it I think next to me
the most mentions in your book is about
John Mayer I am in love with John Mayer
we are in love with each other but you
guys even going like camping trips
together into the right I mean swearing
your children's lives there's never been
anything sexual between you and John yes
I do I swear I swear yeah oh okay all
right yeah is there a chance you will
lose people in terms of friendships
because you are a little bit too chatty
no I think I'm good I think with John
I've said to him many times last year
you know I'm writing a book I'm writing
a diary he does come up a bunch and
regarding Journey regarding that Feud I
was in I think he said to me and I put
it in the book uh he said to me never
get into a feud with an 80s rocker he
he's had a few and he said they're
brutal and they never kind of let go
Sarah Jessica listens to radio Andy a
lot and I'm surprised by the amount she
listens and she often will say to me
that she is so surprised how transparent
I am on the radio about what I'm doing
and what I'm thinking and who I'm seeing
and I and sometimes when she says that I
wonder uh oh did I say something about
you that you're pissed about but she's
think she would tell me well you're
saying the book you when you've decided
to rent a house out in the Hamptons it
had to be next door to Saturday no
that's not true no it didn't say I
didn't say it had to be next door to her
I said she was next door to her I said I
was all the places in the Hamptons you
went next door I was her Willona Woods
last summer if you got the good times
reference are you like dizzy with your
success when you're next door to Sarah
Jessica Parker come on I see this smile
you can barely contain yourself yeah I
love it I'm not no you love it did you
stop over friends with her for 25 years
almost but to be friends with Sarah
Jessica Parker I would say the first
five years of our friendship I would
look at her and I would say every time I
got an email from her and every time we
were out to dinner I was like
oh holy I really was I was I could
not believe it and this was also the
height of Sex in the City and I'm like
I'm I'm like out with Carrie Bradshaw
right now this is the coolest it does
not actually get cooler than this in my
mind and it was true but it was real I
mean I really was like this is It's I'm
still titillated by our friendship but
I've gotten over the excitement of the
newness of it and the
um oh you know I can't believe this I
mean at some point 20 something years
into a friendship you kind of you digest
that it's there
foreign